andrew sandberg welcome to how the light
gets in festival well thank you
as the title of one of your books
exploring human enhancement from 600 bc
to 2050 suggests
human enhancement is nothing new
humans have always used tools or
substances to enhance their health
their thought their physical strength
why are philosophers talking about a
potential future
leading to transhumanism to a future
that transcends our human nature
well the difference now from let's say
the epic of gilgamesh back here and many
thousands of years bc is of course that
now it's a little bit more a realistic
prospect to do something about aging we
actually got crisper we actually got
small molecules that seem to affect the
metabolic pathways affecting aging it
actually looks like this could actually
happen
while the epic of gilgamesh was talking
about this age-old yearning oh we we're
mortal we do not want to be mortal how
do we explain our place in the universe
and we still of course need that
explanation because even if we
technically and clinically can fix some
of our shortcomings as humans we still
need to think about which aspects of
being human actually are shortcomings
which of these changes might actually
promise more than they can uphold and
what should we consider when we change
ourselves in order to change into
something better rather than just
something different so you're someone
who works a lot also on existential risk
uh big threats to our the very survival
of humanity
is a transhumanist future a kind of
existential threat
to humanity given that humanity as we
know it will no longer really be around
some people think so francis fukuyama
famously wrote the book our posthumous
future where he threw every argument he
could imagine on the wall to try to
argue that human enhancement was really
bad it was risky it would be having a
lot of bad effects on society but deep
down there was this argument that it
might change what it really means to be
a human in such a way that it's not
appropriate for humans to want to do
that change now transhumanism as a
moment would respond by saying no no
wanting to change myself is one of the
most human things ever that's close to
the core of what it means to be a human
trying to become better
maybe failing at it but still trying
now there is still a lot of risk
involved in changing our inner self you
really want to be very careful before
you start modifying bodies on a large
scale
we've seen in the past that many
technologies over promise but there's
also another interesting link to
existential risk many of the earliest
people were concerned about existential
threats to humanity were also
transhumanists and that might seem very
strange because aren't trans humans
these techno-optimists who thinks that
we can solve everything with some
non-machines in the future why would
they go on about total extinction or
worse things and the reason is of course
if you're really optimistic about the
future you really want to get there and
you want to safeguard it and may want to
make sure it happens
you might also be open to radical
changes and if you can have a radical
change for good you can also perhaps
have radical change for bad and for the
worse so you really want to safeguard
against that and then comes with finally
the cherry on top if you're optimistic
about the future you also think that we
can do something about the threats
facing humanity and get to the lovely
futures that might be possible if you
think the future is meh in that case why
save it and besides if you think you
can't actually do anything useful to and
improve our chances well why are we even
talking maybe we should just go to the
pub and then drown our sorrows well the
transhumanist optimistic view that maybe
there is something we can do and the
future could become radically well is a
good reason to also try to fix things
like bioweapons nuclear weapons asteroid
impacts and trying to make sure that if
we get artificial intelligence it's safe
and beneficial and aligned with our
interests
so some of the some of the fundamental
worries around you know human
enhancement is what its impact will be
as you mentioned already on the kind of
political landscape will it be
democratic will it be elises will it
lead to particular groups of people
becoming superior beings and while the
rest of us you know remain our mere
mortal selves
do you think there's a way of
guaranteeing that any of the these
future changes will be democratic and
will be distributed more widely or will
it inevitably always be a kind of elite
there
i feel i don't think elitism is given
but then again democracy is interesting
because it's open-ended so you can never
guarantee anything if it's truly an open
society and a democratic choice because
people might actually choose something
completely unexpected
but i do think that we can kind of
shuffle the deck in a particular way so
it's more likely that you get a more
egalitarian outcome uh or avoid some of
the obvious fault modes for example one
reason why we might see of elites having
enhancement on the rest not is that
enhancement is very very expensive now
it turns out that turning drugs and
gadgets into something cheap is
relatively doable we've got mass
production the prices tend to come down
exponentially and soon the smartphones
are in everybody's pocket
it's services that tend to be expensive
so if the enhancements require that you
need to go to an enhancement spa or you
need special education in that case they
might be a more elite thing so we might
want to work very hard on developing
enhancement that are actually
commodities
conversely we might also recognize that
actually health care and education are
in fact actually in fact regarded as so
good services that we subsidize and want
to ensure that everybody gets them
sometimes things that are fairly
expensive can still be seen as important
for societies we support it
i think many of these fears are that we
project the standard worries about
inequality onto enhancement it's many of
the worries about power and wealth
inequality but there might be other
forms of inequality right now for
example when we think about covet 19 and
it's aftermath it's very clear that
there's some people who are resisting
taking vaccines and wearing masks and
might say oh i want a natural immunity
none of us artificial ones they might
actually be the ones that don't want to
enhance themselves we might actually get
these weird slices through society not
so much the traditional elite versus
non-elite but it might be going along
other directions which might pose
tremendously weird political challenges
there's a question about whether
transhumanism is a kind of escapism
right i try and attempt to sort of avoid
our problems today and say that well
there's a better future we can create
that and then we'll solve everything
when people might say well we do have
the resources to solve these problems
now and hear things like climate change
it's just a matter of will what do you
what do you think about that
well if you believe that the future is
going to become better you can be
passive about it you can just say okay
i'm just going to wait around here in my
room until the future has become
glorious and then go out and enjoy the
glorious future
but that's of course not a very good way
of dealing with it especially since that
glorious future gets designed by other
people it might actually be full of
values that you don't approve of at all
if you're optimistic about the future
you want to go out and fix things
and it's an interesting situation when
you look at the current problems in the
world which of these problems could you
fix using technology or social changes
quite often for example people say oh we
can't fix climate change with
technological fixes and then they
promote and promote totally unrealistic
ideas but oh we all need to have joint
will and make it central for our
civilization and maybe and accept to be
poorer wait a minute this is a sociofix
as just as unrealistic as saying oh the
non-machines will fix it in 50 years
time it might be possible that we can
change our global mindset but then again
i regard that as equally up to as for
our argument as the nano machines
so instead it's interesting to look at
where things coincide for example many
of the technology consumers have been
very interested in like artificial
intelligence and automation are also
very useful for fixing many of the
problems in the world if you want
recycling to work it's not just about
getting people to throw the right things
in the right colored bins you actually
want robots to do that recycling for you
because it will never be efficient if
you leave it to people and don't pay
them for it
if you really want resources to be
widely available you need to develop the
biotechnologies and nanotechnologies
that allow you to make them in a low
energy way and that way you also avoid
the carbon emissions of making them by
heating up stuff to high temperatures
there are a lot of technological things
that can improve in the climate
situation which we have seen for example
when it comes to solar power and other
renewables but also plenty of
interesting technology needed to make
them work many of these ones are also of
course of transhumanist interest if you
can make really great batteries to get
the power grid to be green good that's
also good for the cyborg implants
because i don't want to have change
batteries in my arm all the time
ironically one of the most transhuman or
posthumous things we have is the
smartphone which was developed of course
partially for convenience but have
totally changed our mindset our
political discourse or even way of
thinking about ourselves and the
landscape
so quite a lot of these technologies
to creep up on us
so you've also recently been selected to
the swedish ai advisory board for the eu
what is a philosopher doing on a ai
advisory board well advice of course
one of the fun things about philosophy
is that it makes you a bit of a
generalist so you might not know
anything about a particular topic but
you know about how to reason about it
and in this case some part of that
advice is mostly
how can the european union have a
competitive advantage of doing
artificial intelligence in an ethical
manner one of the big problems is
normally you tend to regard ethics as
something that's bad for your business
it's an extra cost maybe you can stamp
the ethical product on your product and
maybe that sells a little bit better
but that's it but i think actually there
is a good chance that if we manage this
right
there is a chance of making artificial
intelligence that is safer and better in
a lot of different directions
one of the big problems with artificial
intelligence is that it ideally must be
value aligned with humans as it becomes
more powerful otherwise we end up with
technologies that transform the world
around us but not in a way aligned with
what we want or can survive
so from my perspective that safety is
really important from a more everyday
business and political perspective you
still want products that do what people
tell them after all we hate when our
computer doesn't do what we wanted to do
we want the butler robot to figure out
our needs and desires
and that's already along that line we
want to figure out ways of reducing the
political and other biases in machine
learning and monitor what we do
here we find a lot of values that
actually are aligned between both ethics
and philosophy and what businesses
actually can make money from and what
politicians would like you to say now
this is of course still proposals we're
telling you what we're thinking to a
member of a committee who might or might
not be able to sway the final document
which
might not be amended by a parliament
that has various random agendas
but i think it's important as a
philosopher to be participating in the
public conversation not just sitting in
your ivory tower saying i know what the
right thing is if anybody were ever to
listen to me
ai is is often sort of vilified or often
sort of exaggerated as as being in
competition with humanity again you know
films like
uh terminator x jsx machina and so on
what is is is ai going to play a a role
you think in transhumanist future is is
it going to be not a kind of
opposition between humanity and i are
the two going to
cooperate in some way
so artificial intelligence is in many
ways a mirror we hold up against
ourselves many of the fears about
artificial intelligence are fierce about
what humans and the human intentions and
some of them are not unfounded after all
if we can use automation artificial
intelligence to amplify our own
abilities that means that some people's
abilities get amplified even though the
rest of us might very well want them not
to you don't want automated identity
theft you don't want dictators to be
able to command a robot army that will
never ever say no when in order to
commit atrocities
and that is just the most obvious
low-hanging
fruits
we might also look into the situations
where we get artificial intelligence
helping us make much better decisions
solve fundamental very hard problems
that are beyond human ability
there are some people saying oh if you
can't beat them join them we should be
kind of merging with machines which is
an old transhumanist vision
the earliest ideas about this go back
actually in the to the writings of
bernal in the early part of the 20th
century where he's sketching out various
possibilities for future and pointing
out that settling space is probably
going to
require us replacing parts of our
biology with technology and eventually
becoming
partially or wholly artificial later on
manfred clients in the 60s looking at
the real nasa space program had similar
ideas and coined the word cyborg for
these integrations now the problem is
it's easier probably to upgrade a device
than a brain certainly brains have a lot
of flexibility and plasticity but it's
easy to run a little update on a piece
of software so it might be that the
artificial part can more easily run away
and they develop much further than the
biological part of us but then again we
want to have our values the influence of
artificial parts that's the key thing
after all in some sense our brains are
kind of appendages for an
or spinal cord helping the spinal cord
to do the right stuff it's just that it
does a little bit more than just help
the spinal cord move around in space and
find food we're thinking about food
we're feeling about food we're thinking
and reacting to other threats we're
building up internal worlds in some
sense our brain has taken over from the
spinal cord yet the spinal cord sets
some of the initial agendas let's stay
alive let's function as an organism
and i think maybe what we can hope for
as humanity is to become an integrated
part inside so to say the body of
whatever super civilization emerges that
might be mostly artificial but yet we
are kind of that spice that gives it
soul and heart
so you're someone who sort of puts his
money where his mouth is as it were
you've arranged for your body to be
frozen after your death and you know be
reawoken in some kind of future if this
hypothetical fusion were to have
invented say a cure for death what would
you want to do with your life knowing
that you know there's no end to it now
well there is so much to do the problem
is even
if i knew that i could go on arbitrary
long
time is still linear
while i'm reading a good book there are
thousands of authors out there writing
other good books and there's so much
research to be done that we don't know
yet that we even need to do
so i think the problem is i would like
to branch out i was wanted to have
copies i want to be uploaded and be able
to have not just backup copies but
parallel copies
because the universe
is really rich it's much more complex
than a single mind can understand and
even a collective of mine is unable to
truly understand it because it's a
universe containing collectives of mind
making complicated art complicated
thoughts that is of course by nature
just as complex as what we're thinking
so we are always going to be struggling
for prioritizing of understanding and
creating more creating art creating
games creating new little virtual worlds
creating big virtual worlds simulating
the past present and future
so what i want to do if i get an
arbitrary amount of time is of course
adding to the universe
it's such an interesting universe but i
think we can make it even better
a lot of philosophers have argued that
our sort of mortality our finitude is
part of what gives life meaning people
like heidegger and thinking even bernard
williams in the paper called the
markopoulos case
do you think they're wrong about that do
you think it isn't mortality that sort
of gives human life its meaning i i
think it's a mistake i think it's a bit
like arguing that it's divorce that give
makes love have meaning
in some sense yes the fine attitude and
the risk adds a particular spice and
structure to it
but i think the most important aspect is
that everything is in some sense mortal
because eventually the proton decay or
the heat depth of the universe will get
every form of structure there is
very very very very far in the future
but if i were to live for a billion year
or 10 years
from a heideggerian perspective does
that matter
that perspective actually doesn't
include an explicit uh measure of time
it's just the fact that my life is
finite that matters but that's going to
be fine that even if i'm opposed human
who's going to live for trillions of
years i'm still going to have to face
eventually that my black hole power
systems are going to run out in some icy
very dark age in the far future
and in that case i'm just as mortal as a
mayfly from the perspective of infinite
but normally we care about what we fill
the time with
normally we might say that a long rich
life is better than a short rich life
because there was more rich moments
there was more other things and i do
think they add up
but different people might live very
different structures over life there are
some people who format their lives in a
very different way from what i might do
and they might actually say yeah i don't
need more than this amount of time and
then i'm done well i think right now
given how i'm functioning i would just
add more and more goals and we kind of
get stressed oh no it's only a 50
trillion years on the heater for the
universe and i hardly start that
andersenberg thank you very much thank
you
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv
[Music]
you